leadership is about your team and about
the people and about
creating constructs and frameworks
for them to
fully realize their vision
[Music]
diane betcher thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders how are
you
i'm good i'm good thank you thanks for
having me pleasure to be here
thank you very much for joining me we
have so much to talk about in so little
time
because we are going to talk about your
experience in the military in the techno
technology side being deployed overseas
to afghanistan but transitioning to
being a keynote speaker
to and leading with kindness and when i
think of a military setting in
afghanistan transitioning to keynote
speaking of leading with kindness
there's gonna be a little bit i'm sure
there's a dissonance there
but then being an architect manager at
microsoft
er so a lot of a lot of experiences that
i want to learn from but
i i like to start with with the hardest
question which is tell me tell me a
little bit about yourself and where you
come from
yes so great question um as as you
uh could probably guess from my accent i
am american although i've
lived most of my adult life outside of
the continental us
some of that due to my military career
some of it due to my civilian career so
um yeah like you said pretty diverse
background um
i think myself you know you mentioned my
title as an architect manager i think of
myself as a leader more than as a
manager
and we always say that we manage things
and lead people
right and both need to be done leaders
and organizations need to be paying
attention to both sides of that because
you always have to manage budgets and
time
and resources and things like that but
people should never be thought of as
things and so we lead people
and so um yeah i joined the navy
right out of college um i went to flight
school
um not a pilot though most of the time
when i say i flew reconnaissance
aircraft uh
people oh you're you know you're a pilot
no
so a lot of people have seen top gun so
maverick and goose
right goose i was in the back
ran the mission uh you know hollering
out you know do some of that pilot stuff
the thing that i enjoy most about this
show is is really
you know i understanding the junctions
and the decision making processes
why you know it's it could correct me if
i'm wrong but it's not the default
path for many young women out of college
to go to flight school in the navy
especially in a technological position
sure sure um okay so i consider myself
one of the first digital natives
both of my parents worked for a computer
company when i was growing up
and back then computers took up rooms
and
a college might a college might have one
computer
and in fact that's what my mother did my
mother has a background in education
and she sold computers to engineering
schools and they weren't really sure
they needed a computer
right they've been teaching engineering
for for many years and they weren't sure
they needed a computer
to do it um and the ceo of the company
man named uh mr norris believed
computers were going to change the world
and they belonged in the homes and
everybody thought that was crazy
and they said what would they do with it
what would you do with a computer in
your house and he's like well i don't
know
so let's give them to people and so he
reached out to his employee base and he
said who has young children
and he gave us a main prank terminal so
i was about
10 or 11 years old and we got a
mainframe terminal on my house this was
an old 300
baht acoustical modem right and you're
like pounding it into the cradle
and and we did what you know teenagers
do right we
played games and talked to boys um
that's
so very early on exposed to technology
exposed to
that kind of um
[Music]
you know part of the world if you will
um and so
yeah when i um graduated from college
and i was joining the navy
um this was you know late 80s
mid 80s um very much appreciative of the
freedoms
that we enjoy here in the united states
i felt it was
you know important to put my hand at the
wheel uh you know
take my turn at the or if you will and
um and join the military so i did
um and then i was like well they
actually
at the time women weren't allowed on um
to
serve on ships but there was some
interesting things happening
in um in the aviation side of the house
and so that's why i decided to go there
wow okay so and how long how long did
you serve for
um i actually just retired um between
active dating and reserves i served 30
years
wow 30 years so i i lo
i have to no all of a sudden jump a
little bit because today
i'm going to skip for now about the
leading with candice we'll go we'll come
back to this but i have to now
talk about being a leader at microsoft
being a leader
in in the navy deployed overseas
managing critical infrastructure at both
companies different types of
infrastructure i'm sure and different
technologies i'm sure
what were some commonalities and some
differences that you're seeing
oh yeah so um
so the couple of places where i was you
know managing infrastructure so in
addition to
being deployed to afghanistan as a
civilian i managed um
a network in germany as well as one on
the continent of africa
and a little country called djibouti
which we just have to admit is fun to
say
um so
um and i think that one of the things
that
is is common across it is that
we've really moved from seeing
technology as an as an extra
as it was when i was young to being
infrastructure
right that we we can no longer think
of technology as internet access of
um the capabilities that are brought to
us with technology
as um a nice to have
they are a must right it's powering it
really is
at the same time we don't see
the um i don't see the operators right
so whether that's the
um you know the people who fly the
aircraft who
you know who pick up the weapons in the
military or
in a business context you know it would
be your sellers your customer
engagement really understanding what's
happening with the technology
and so as a leader in technology a lot
of times what we
we're spending our energy on is
helping those business leaders helping
those operational leaders
understand the capabilities and and the
constraints
that the technology brings to it so for
example in the military we would often
you know have to talk to you know some
of the senior leaders about how we had
to
you know we have to take down the
servers and do you know patch
maintenance on them
so this was before the cloud right and i
mean for
virtual machines and we would actually
have to take you know have an outage
in order to update wow and install the
patches on the servers
and we'd have to explain to you know
very senior people that we would have to
take down
the system um and a lot of times they go
well i never have to do that with my
router at home
it's like well yes sir that's because
your router at home is owned
right like the adversary probably is on
it because you've never patched it
and we don't want that happening to our
servers so we have to take it down
and so then we would would try to say
well you know you wouldn't fly an
aircraft for 30 days
without maintaining you wouldn't fire a
weapon
for 60 days without taking you know
disassembling it and cleaning it and
maintaining it right oh right
yeah okay well we have to do that with
the technology as well
and so a lot of both in business and in
the military
a lot of what it is is helping those
business leaders helping the operational
leaders
understand both the limitations and the
capabilities like what are the cool
things they can do
with the technology i'd love to
transition a little bit and talking
about
leadership as we as we continue in your
journey
so you finish your
your duty right you're still in reserve
duty but you finish your active duty
and you are now trying to be a keynote
speaker and
help others understand better living
with kindness what does that mean
so it's got dual meetings right so
so first of all it's it's being about
being a kind leader
right it's about um leading isn't about
yelling
leading isn't about the being the one in
charge leading isn't it
is about being kind um it's also
a little bit of a double antenna that
you know when you lead with something
it's
the thing that comes first right so it's
showing up first with kindness like
whatever else
comes along the kindness needs to show
first um and
i think a lot of people misunderstand
the way the military
leads you know you've served and other
people
who have served understand that it's not
just about yelling orders
it's about helping people share the
vision
like understand what are we doing here
what are we trying to accomplish
and then getting out of people's way
right and letting
their creativity their passion their
innovation their energy
make that vision come true and you
can't you can't do that if people don't
share the vision
and they're not going to share the
vision with you
if you're mean though it's just as
simple as that
um you know if you think about that why
why so passionate about this
where does this innate passion that
you're saying i want to dedicate myself
now to ex to sharing this passion with
others
where does this come from i think well i
think our world
lacks leaders and i think our world
lacks
the good examples of leaders i think too
many people
learn about what it's like to be a
leader through
through the media through hollywood
through through fictional depictions
and a fictional depiction of you know
eisenhower you know standing you know
with those
uh paratroopers the night before d-day
and just talking with them that's not
dramatic
right that doesn't that doesn't sell
tickets right so you
we end up with the cake box boss you
know yelling at people
it you know and we end up thinking that
that's what leadership
is and it's it's not
it's not but the quiet humble leaders
um who are out there doing the hard work
of getting to know their people
and helping their people lifting their
people up
um we don't see that portrayed so we
have this misunderstanding of what it
means to lead and be a leader
and i think we we lack that
in our communities we lack that in our
schools we like that in our
you know in our workplaces and it
doesn't have to be like that
work doesn't have to be terrible we
spend so much
of our day at work why would we
want it to be a turmoil why would we
want it to be
so difficult why can't it be and i think
it can't i think it can be a place where
we grow when we thrive and we bring our
full and complete authentic selves
um so where does that come from it just
comes from that you know look
we could be so much better we could have
so much fun at work
we could accomplish so much we can all
win
life isn't a competition right i'm a
gamer too
like that's not my bio i play games all
the time with my kids
and and everything and we play co-op
games
and a co-op game is a game where we all
work together to beat the game
not to beat each other and that's what
life is life's a co-op game
we can all win
as i'm embarking as i'm embarking on my
journey and and i hope to have the
privilege of leading
great teams with with fantastic
motivated
intelligent hard-working people and
what are some things that that i can
take with me from this conversation
you know for the next few decades as
hopefully
a successful leader what what things
should i be keeping in mind that you're
observing that
that are just not an apparent enough in
the world
so leadership isn't about you
leadership is about your team and about
the people and about
creating constructs and frameworks
for them to
fully realize their vision
and as the leader what you do is you set
the overall
larger vision and then
you help people understand how they can
achieve their purpose
in that context and then you know i said
create the frameworks
that allows them to have those
um to bring their passion their
innovation their creativity
right because those are the things you
can't automate those are the things
you know if if it's something where you
know i
always tell my people it's it's they
said well tell me what to do
i said well i could do that i would
write an algorithm
right and i would just have the
algorithm do it what i need from you
is to figure out what i don't know right
so listen to your people understand
that you know they're full and complete
human beings right they're more than
what they bring to work
and so understand what those other
things are about them and what's
important to them
and support them in that and and then
share your vision and
clearly communicate your vision over and
over and over again
the best leaders are those
whose people can imitate them flawlessly
if you're if your people can do a good
imitation of you
it means you're showing up it means
you're being consistent
right i love that i love that because
you know a lot of the people that i
speak to i i ask this question a lot and
a lot of the times i'm hearing responses
like you know a good leader is one that
knows how to hire slow and and fire fast
or a good leader is one that knows how
to articulate the vision
and and takes the team forward rarely
the first response is a good leader is
one who listens
and one who serves by example and has
their people
yearning to to or able to imitate their
their positive qualities like showing up
and being consistent
so i'm taking a lot of a lot of it a lot
of this inspiration and i have to say
that from
my experience in the military i've
gotten to observe great leaders poor
leaders
i've gotten to be a leader myself i've
been i i have been
a good leader i have been a poor leader
and i've learned from both and and it's
a journey that i'm very excited to
continue embarking on
and and then people is everything you
know we
just have a few minutes left but i'd
love to learn a little bit about what
you're doing today at microsoft
and what you chose as your next
challenge and and then obviously
the last and most difficult question
that i'll ask
okay um yeah so as an architect manager
i lead a small team
of uh pretty senior folks which is
really exciting
um all of them have 15 20 years of
industry experience and what they do
is they help our customers um
who are solving the hardest problems um
with our technologies so whether you
know it's
typically you know we're talking fortune
type of customers who are doing big
things or new things
with our technologies and the architects
on my team
help them do that and what so that what
my job is
is to make sure that they have
everything they need
to show up well for our customers and
help our customers succeed
it sounds like an an amazing challenge
that consistently changes consistently
having to adapt
because obviously we're seeing how the
world is changing every single day and
and microsoft is at the forefront of
these changes
and and i i'm sure that it's a pretty
remarkable position
and dan i want to thank you again for
being so generous with your time and i'd
love to end with my favorite question
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
yeah so i'm candid
it's one of my brands i'm candid um
i'm founded in knowledge i like to do my
homework
okay and then the last is compassion
i can definitely see that yeah i love
that
and and i want to again thank you for
for sharing your journey
and i think it's remarkable and i'm
learning so much from from every journey
but
but that transition from the military
setting technological background
and going there with a mission being a
part of missions and then going in
and talking about leading with kindness
and and expressing that side and then
doing it in a place like microsoft i'm
sure that's just phenomenal and
and i'm sure that those architects are
lucky to have you working with them so
they ann
thank you very very much and stay safe
and stay healthy thank you
you too all right thanks